and here's the other thing about being a
true Alpha which is confident in
yourself and not fighting a an
unnecessary war with the world with
everyone around you being able to focus
on things that really matter is that
your control your overbearing will never
ever have the effect that you want you
gotta realize that everything you're
doing to control her behavior literally
has one effect always the only effect
that ever is gonna have is pushing her
away it will never do what you want it's
self-defeat it's just so toxic and if
men understood that they understood how
to address that to little boy in them
that says they're going to leave she's
going to leave and nobody could love me
whatever I'm not good enough if you
could work through that then you will be
a true Alpha emotional maturity is what
make men real and you know I'll tell you
what else women like when men are
sensitive and open up to them every time
100 you want to talk to your girl about
your insecurities guess what she's going
to become more bonded with you